how to hire remote workers successfully
and my business have had a mix of hiring
people remotely and people who also work
you know out of my office and I recently
had to go through the process again of
hiring somebody new remotely as we're
growing and I wanted to share my
experience with you because a lot of
people get this wrong a lot of
entrepreneurs make mistakes here and end
up losing tons of time in the process so
here's the first thing I do it's it's
really important I'll write out
everything that I want the person
understand okay I want them to know what
my company stands for what we're all
what we're all about right helping
entrepreneurs believing in entrepreneurs
I will write what their job entails all
the different tasks that they have to do
and it'll be one big fat messy ugly
paragraph so Evan you're so mean why
would you do that why don't you make it
easy for them to get the information I
don't want it to be easy you know as
part of the job requirement is being
able to work through hard stuff right I
try to make it as easy as possible once
I've hired them I don't want their lives
to be hard but but I need them to be
detail-oriented and see who's a worker
who's not right it's an attitude
somebody will see that huge Peregrine's
I don't want to read that great I don't
want you as part of my company I want
somebody who's gonna take the time to
read it if you start seeing stuff about
believing entrepreneurs and it doesn't
inspire you to keep going if you're not
hungry enough to work for me then I
don't want you as part of my team it's
perfect they've self eliminated
themselves the next thing I'll do is
right in the middle of that ugly nasty
long terrible paragraph I'll ask two
questions one will be how many Twitter
followers do I have and I'll say please
share this as your first sentence in
your response back to me and then I'll
ask them what do you like about
entrepreneurs because if you don't like
entrepreneurs you're not gonna have a
great time working for me so the first
one tests did they actually read that
long paragraph and the second one will
test why do they want this job because
you're not just looking for a bum in a
chair you're looking for someone who's
gonna give you their heart and soul
because they love what you're all about
so I posted the job I got hundreds of
requests
80% of them 80% of them didn't even
mention the Twitter thing that I posted
that means they just saw the ad saw was
a marketing position and they sent in
their cover letter in their resume 80% I
would have burned my time reading all of
their profiles their resumes or cover
letters wasting my time when they spent
five seconds looking at the job at
that's what's gonna happen if somebody
does not say in their first cent is like
I clearly asked how many Twitter
followers do I have then I don't read
their profile it saves me a ton of time
see this is what you need to do this is
why hiring it can be so painful and
frustrating because you bring it on the
wrong people and spending time with the
wrong people
okay so 80% gone I just cut my work down
by a lot next the next 10% wrote
something like I don't know how many
Twitter followers you have because you
didn't give me your account how hard is
it to find Evan Carmichael on Twitter
that was it was a small simple stupid
easy test so all you showed me now is
that you read then read the whole
paragraph but you have zero
resourcefulness to go out and find how
many Twitter followers I have you type
Evan Carmichael Twitter you'll find me
it's not that hard
so those 10% are gone too I don't want
them in my business if I have to explain
every single thing step by step and you
have zero resourcefulness then you're
not gonna be a good fit at my company
and they shouldn't be a good fit at your
company either you should care about
this stuff this is important the last
10% of the ones who actually said how
many Twitter followers I had that's like
baseline right I've already eliminated
90 percent of people who were just
wasting my time who didn't even care
about this those last 10 percent then I
look at what their response was not just
the Twitter followers but how did they
answer the second question why are they
like entrepreneurs do they do they have
it in their blood was a part of their
family what is it and you can tell some
people speak with passion they speak
from the heart I don't care for this job
if they're perfect English or not I'm
not asking to be a writer but I want to
feel something from from their response
they're not just saying I love
entrepreneurs and I hope to be one
someday
that's not what I want so you get down
to like the last two or three percent of
people and then I'll hire them on a
small job a trial job this is something
that they would do for me and I give
them a limit so I'll say you have 10
hours to do this job and I'll give them
like four tasks to do and some people
will take the full ten hours to do it
and some people will will not get it
done within the ten hours and some
people do anything I'll just claim the
ten hours and and so you're losing a
little bit of money on these people but
what you want to see is how long does it
take somebody to do the task
I give them something that is hard and I
see
can they get this done within that ten
hour limit
are they being honest with me if they
finish early are they billing me for ten
hours are they gonna bill me for the 8.5
that they work that's who I want I want
the hustler the one who said I got all
this stuff done and I did it under time
what's up that's who I want to hire so
you can do a lot of the work of
screening people upfront you build the
crazy long paragraph you ask them a
question that is relatively easy to find
if they just read what you wrote you
give them something that relates to what
you're all about something passionate
and see what the response is
and the people who write back and give
them some kind of trial job to test
their skills is test if they're the
right fit for you or not small amount of
money up front but it's worth it for
getting the right person anyway that's
my process it's worked its work
repeatedly I hope you'll use it to make
better hiring decisions I don't want you
to be the entrepreneur who tries to hire
somebody it doesn't work out and you say
this is not for me I can't hire people
I'm gonna do it myself because that's
not how you have a real impact in the
world you've got to bring people on and
it's tough and it's harder you make
mistakes and the first person you hire
is probably gonna not gonna last with
you right it just happens but I want you
to minimize your mistakes and I want you
to believe that the hiring people can
work and you can you can bring on people
to really help you build something
powerful so that's how I do it believe
you guys liked this video please give it
a thumbs up below I'd love to hear what
you have to think you have a question
about my process you want to learn more
leave it below you have another question
about your business in general leave it
below in the
let me give you the response thank you
guys so much and I'll see you soon